i'm from a small west african country
liberia
and because of the civil war my wife and
i fled liberia
we have no intentions of leaving
but when the war came
we decided we had to survive
and that's how we started that process
to come to this country
i'm will matt collins and i'm the mayor
of city of helena montana
[Music]
when wilma collins gained refugee status
and moved to the united states in 1994
he came to helena montana a town of
about 30 000 people that doesn't see a
lot of change
more than two decades later he decided
to run for mayor of helena challenging a
popular 16-year incumbent
when i became an american i said
i wanted to run for office but as time
would come closer and closer i got
scared because i didn't know the
processes
i wasn't trained to be a mayor come on
let's see
last year
my son came home and said dad we need to
talk
your time is now you have to run
he pushed me and pushed me and finally i
said okay i'm going to run
and i didn't run on
on a refugee platform i ran on a
platform that would
serve my community
hi how are you i met with people i
participated in every
political public forum
that was held
i didn't shy away because i knew the
hard questions had to be answered
in helena montana a first-time candidate
beat a 16-year incumbent the first
african-american mayor in montana
history an unlikely leader in a state
where only half a percent of the
population looks like him
you know when i when i got elected
it immediately became overwhelming i
have to tell you
within the first nine days we had 30
plus interviews from everywhere
so when huffington post called and said
how does it feel to make history i said
what history i was just running a small
town elections no are you aware you're
the first
african-american
mayor in the history of the state of
montana i said no i didn't think about
it
you see and to crown it off you're
you're a former refugee
as time went on i realized it was more
than just me
if i wilmar collins
could do that here in helena
others can see and say hey we can
emulate him
i have opened up the door
the day-to-day is
busy no doubt
but
it's rewarding discussion administrative
services
and i think the city is doing well
interacting
with the community
is very important
that's why the first wednesday of the
month i meet with the community i say
hey
talk to me what's going on
how can we make this place a better
place
how can we continue to work together
i'm pleased to say that
my community is one of the most
accepting community you can think about
in this country
a lot of people have their own
interpretation of who a refugee is
but
it's not fun
fleeing your country fleeing what you
know
going into a totally strange environment
that you know nothing about
coming into this country when i got in
the first thing i started hearing was
people say oh the immigrants they're
refugees they're going to soak up our
resources
they're not going to contribute to this
community
it's not true
we want to give back to our host country
we want to give back to the country that
gave us that second chance
this is our country and we will do the
best for it
thanks for having
[Applause]
[Music]
you